first I'm trying to figure out how to
get into this phone with a new update hi
I'm Hannah Hart I'm mamrie Hart and I'm
great pelvic it all been definitely a
picture of myself yeah sitting right in
this chair give me your thumbs up the
last one I have that wasn't just a
selfie from this morning is a picture of
flowers that Hannah sent me yesterday
yeah I sent her flowers cuz she
announced me at the GLAAD Awards last
thing I googled was pictures of Ruby
Rose oh trying to get outfit inspo the
first thing that pops up is I was going
on StubHub to look up Garth Brooks
tickets oh and then the other window was
Thailand weather in October I'm getting
the hell out of here
my window wanted how many windows do you
have open I like I use my phone a lot I
don't know your fembot oh right cuz you
said I look like a fembot you did yeah
and I've added the nicest thing anyone's
ever said about me I have one alarm from
this morning set it says brick leg I
like to set my alarms with little like
affirmations like you're doing great or
like good job or less what I don't know
sometimes I just write like I love you
what yeah I have nothing set no playoffs
whoa totally free wait those are all of
your alarms this is crazy but I don't
have any why would you set in the lawn
for 10:00 a.m. that's a leaf not all of
us are morning people Hannah the yellow
heart and then kissy-face kids and then
shocked face you're shocked a lot I am
care of mine raise hands and the old man
face which I also love a lot you do yes
you're just so like old old and fine
with it
my most Jews is the Rockingham followed
by the two dancing girls which I just
did the phone update and I don't like
how realistic they look now let me see
they used to be chubby little bunnies
and now they look like women
[Music]
never used one once she refuses a few
not say Miguel bitmoji and no filters
that's not true come on lemma I always
go to the beauty filter yeah I've never
put it on that's how I look I swear to
god you do this look you take a little
of this ah and then do a little of that
oh yeah yeah that's a filter right no I
don't do any of the like look on the
that finger this is that filter doesn't
just brighten it smooths out your entire
schedule you meant the one that makes
you like contoured oh oh no no you've
never used that 1s app I downloaded it
was a great app called dish it's like
instagram meets Yelp is dish so you can
look at beautiful pictures of food and
see how good the meals are my last
downloaded venmo Oh like pay people
I'll pen draw you a dollar right now 900
more times
[Music]
mine is currently on Britney Spears
radio it's a playing timberlake on the
Britney Pandora which happens often
which i think is controversial yeah my
most recently played songs are like this
running playlist that I have and so it's
like a lot of Adele you run the hello
sometimes I used to at first now I don't
even have a farm I read I rent a total
eclipse of the heart oh yeah oh really
fine wrecking ball well you've run to
some sad stuff I love those pretty good
to run to it's like that course comes in
and you're like yeah wrecking ball
running yeah never knew the word